oh my god people you don't want me to
start talking about keto and
intermittent fasting Marno what's your
current dietary philosophies personally
we had some Korean barbecue that we
bought on my birthday you know my
birthday was on the 28th and two days
ago was like the fifth I was like it's
still good right
wasn't it still good I mean it's tasty
kinda a glass of milk were half the milk
stays on the side of the glass because
it's also not good and then you feel
horrible about it did you know that was
the weird part I had the same thing I
had my coffee creamer and it would come
out and it was like these chunks would
come out and my brain didn't connect
that that meant it was spoiled
I drank chunky coffee for three days
before I eventually realized oh it's my
milk was not chunky like it didn't feel
chunky when I was drinking it was after
I drank it I looked in the glass and
there was just the sides of the glass
were white it was supposed to be a clear
glass I want to be clear Wade and I same
situation the same chunky coffee I had
he did it worse his block of the kitty
cat okay hey [ __ ] you dude man you know
what wait you didn't swear the whole
talking part today the Olson video games
began almond on my keyboard gross here
was it still smooth
[Music]
yeah you'd be a good boy you don't need
to yell at every random person that
moderately inconveniences you did you
murder my family you know I mean for any
reasons for legal reasons I didn't also
I forgot to play okay good job being
able to play a game and talk at the same
time I suck at everything I'm a
troubling almonds into my mouth and I'm
still winning it who knew now you'd now
you're winning I was gonna not win on
now you're technically winning you're
technically all that coming in my third
eye I saw that and oddly I'm Arnie
winning would have been your hand so I
guess you would have seen it you're a
dream and I'm that guy who plays just
real good no I've only met excuse e once
and you know I don't talk to him
regularly but I am never gonna let that
go like and I don't know why but I just
like I find it the funniest thing and I
think I'll be on my deathbed and I will
remember the moment that he made a
stupid move in chess that I would have
also made because I don't play chess but
I've never honored by your grandchildren
and their holographic wrist bones and
look up at them and be like you remember
[Laughter]
what did I just do the almonds finally
betrayed game where you can put a
microphone input wins and you just have
to scream you know into your mic and a
lot of you scream it the less likely it
is someone's able to get it before you I
mean true to life then right hey when do
we flip yeah
actually well I'm one of those oh that's
different
that's different close enough I don't
know what that little fold you asked for
weighted delivers way delivered oh I'm
like this at all I don't have this color
well don't don't barn but don't bedont
oh that just not wait
sorry guys we're done ten seconds look I
didn't have any control over that this
new game-mode is so nuanced and cool
I hope Bob doesn't win great that was
almost fun for a second thing yeah man I
was almost having a good time mr.
almonds over here woman can I just say
I'm I'm enjoying myself right now
because the sound of me talking while
eating almonds makes me sound like every
fat guy from every movie ever to had the
conversation while shoving food in his
face and I don't know why that makes why
that makes me laugh but it does there's
not enough lip smacking still though
yeah you don't bite him with your lips
come on Wade don't be stupid what
happened what why everybody suck a big
dick everyone what is that I'm frozen
I'm challenging got a question mark no
you didn't have the thing the the
obvious thing that I would and of course
two could play it three can play at this
game Wade whatever that means
mark make it a normal color I don't and
hang on we're going twice I think that's
a wild I think that's a wild draw four
whatever buddy just looks super crazy
listen more
I'm like really sorry five oh that's a
lot get them
I don't know what that does that comes
back to you I think it could skip Oh it
basically just means play again and that
card is just pointless and you guys
believe how different it feels to play
mmm lip instead of regular uno I mean it
does I don't know why you're seeing in
that kind of a tone I'm saying the same
thing why you mean so you better be
raised to draw never lie ah I see is it
draw until it you find the 2 3 4 5 skip
through my loop when you play this card
the next player must draw until they get
a color of your choosing interviews
their turn what are you reading
you can quit click the question mark
under the far right I don't believe you
and I don't trust you I'm not gonna
click it ok man you guys ever realized
how the last elements at the bottom of
the bag are like a really extra salty
because all the salts down there yeah
man
finally I do notice that lots of the
salt I get salt alright
blood pressure am i right yeah don't you
have high blood pressure wait isn't that
like a thing you need to not do yeah
yeah I know I avoid salt like the plague
okay perfect all right I'm supposed to
eat bananas and not eat salt why bananas
they help lower them for you yeah sure
flushes stuff out of your system or
something I don't know obviously my
blood pressure has always been
borderline a little high it's always
like on the line it's never been super
high but it's always been close up to
the lineman like you better be careful
you are closed well c'mon snap right
oh that is that is quite a reference but
I should have got a Professor Oak icon
in uno like his picture was Professor
Oak and he had some voices on his a XLR
that said those lines that's why I
remember the mandy and i streamed
pokemon snap like two weeks ago the next
week they announced the switch a switch
sequel for pokemon snap it's coming in
it you didn't so we made it happen i
will take what does it matter he didn't
he needed to draw it you're wrong who do
you who do you do and just categorically
wrong one doesn't switch i can't enable
that and flip look we don't need it man
it's that's a chaos rule anyway why okay
and we're back right now it's game on
everybody three i guess good evergreen
oh yeah you can see the cards oh man
this game is oh there's so many levels
flip it's crazy oh yeah
take this hmm 7 plus 7 is 14 14 divided
by 3 is not a whole number try to do a
conspiracy theory but i couldn't the
luckiest number the geometry is all
wrong if there's okay well i have one of
those yeah wait here's a three laugh
left left left left
is there a keyboard shortcut to call FRU
no i don't think so i think i know if
there's the keyboard truck jump in one
okay let me call you out like that but
you know i'm me so i did because
how you guys beat me do I was so fast we
I was so fast
Bob 69 Bob take this is are you asking
me or take it no take it
mmm take it he has a green eight and a
yellow eight wave get him all right you
guys are teaming up on me huh oh yeah
you think I don't have a counter to that
yeah but you know I definitely do now
watch this no no no I had a Harvey
that's what you get that's what they
deserve you repay no way oh ha ha
eat my song get a Murphy oh you didn't
so any more drawing cards I'm waiting I
just oh all right well I just sit here
and watch I guess that's fine no it was
supposed to be yellow oh sorry
calm down like that or we're gonna think
you're having a stroke oh well this is
really building up quite that listen
it's it's a deck building game you want
to get them up dude belly games are mr.
friends never that game we play at your
place there's a deck building must have
a DC deck marvel ultimate no DC deck
building marvel ultimate DC deck build
[Music]
you wanted to have sex with that kitty
not five minutes ago the way you're
looking at the cat is very deeply
concerning and he looks unhappy about it
I don't like this also it's playing sexy
music what did you do wait wait what
have you done what are you about to do
that how do you explain yourself in
directions I have questions but no
answers interesting this isn't a pop
song from the 90's just say what you
mean say what you mean to say Oh daddy's
got a brand-new booth
just wait interesting why isn't this +5
also count as a five you're lucky you're
lucky my skin's you're lucky I feel
lucky thank you
very lucky that is not the color this is
the only color okay never mind
interesting I shall play this that was
fun and then I shall play this look at
the plays yeah you know I'm right there
with you though you better watch out do
you have no idea oh you think you think
you think you don't think are key please
[Laughter]
interesting oh he drew a bunch of cards
that's right okay I'm not upset I got my
Just Desserts there I think third place
is a good one first tourists a Wade's
autobiography is it points based on how
many cards the other players have the
numbers in their cards might matter to
I'm not sure how it's done
oh god no that's right hey well it's not
a draw so I don't even matter no I mean
I had a skip and I you have a different
I didn't see it more of it don't you
know me you were really twisted my nips
a my twisted harder
oh absolutely huh read to me
[ __ ] you shouldn't have said anything I
think you know never mind
hang on a second no no no no no I think
it should be more embarrassed that you
can even make that sound I think that
looks bad on you and that doesn't look
bad on me at all yeah that's really sad
fun cards no problem
oh god I refuse mark listen I don't
think that snacks - hey what's it taste
like
your soundboard man right it makes me
know I wasn't ready like me you whoo
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no no stop too
late I can't change for you chose poorly
for me or you for everyone but me right
[Laughter]
wait would you like to go back to the
normal dimension sure holy [ __ ] we don't
both have no okay only one of us is a
real champion here
Oh No pathetic I was not paying
attention to your card I did not see
what doesn't matter all right now the
game starts for realsies wait all right
oh oh well okay he probably doesn't have
it mm-hmm
I think he has blue though ah I don't
know anyone caught the subtle hint well
I mean he'd had two blues and you had
your one yellow and that's you know I
avoid that with the green just plus five
of the death plus five hit him okay good
one Wade thank you thank you
ah wait but he doesn't have does he know
he does sit and he does not I'm sorry
I'm sorry
hey listen I believe you what is this
music
what no no but someone check the vod's
someone clip it was I'm afraid how would
that help I just want to know the truth
man just wanna know the Karen you know
the truth is Mark that I don't like the
truth
- dude you need to stop speaking your
truth this is rough that's I just don't
I can't face this truth what you yell i
won I'm part of it god I am some I'm
like brick from anchorman sometime just
over your stupid mayonnaise into the
toaster like every other person Oh yuck
and I like everyone else
memorize everyone's hands
[Music]
memory it's called eidetic photographic
what is happening gaiz you can have so
many reverses this is terrible am i
going or what oh okay nice thanks Archie
oh did the - okay cool and you really
take an offense from this cat he's an
[ __ ]
we've dict you over way harder than he
asked you know I'm still not like you
with Barbra with no one is like you with
Barbra
yeah no one wow that's pretty Savage I
think Barbara's fine oh wait ha wait no
hang on I didn't I see jump and I I see
jump and I jump - jump in mark trip in
Shipibo I'm trying get him apparently I
don't have the card laughingstock yeah I
looked away and he has 19 yellow mark
has a green wait wait wait wait wait
wait okay I have one of those hey come
on now
you don't call anyone else's cards edge
is mine it's unfair I mean we can all
see the green of the yellow in the back
of your hand
you were about to win so it's unfair you
were afraid I was gonna win where you
wade okay
don't change the coat well this is a
little rude why would I help you
small hand oh come on because big hands
and small hands hold well
I'm sorry you say that again so I get
that for my soundboard big hands and
small hands hold well perfect Bob what
am I doing here
oops get out here
okay mr. YouTube reaction man okay buddy
you one of those a-holes that plays
scary games on YouTube and you think I
can be beaten by something like this so
Ben you asked I was right there see all
right look holy [ __ ] that's loud what
I'm sorry Bob I listen it's fine I just
blasted my own ears with something
accidentally for a second and it shocked
me out of existence I don't know why I
was trying to get your attention
I was just gonna get screwed not
everything against you is done with
malice wait but this is kinam oh I'm
gonna get him yeah I'll get you remember
how we got weighed we're buddies yep
well I could be one of these cool guys
[Music]
go again oh oh hey that we were me yeah
[Music]
what I hate you draw so many cards right
now no you're not you're draw three even
though I drew like thirty less hadn't
that happened to me I don't understand
fine don't Oh humans are you even what
is this look man I don't know garbage
maybe like four percent Neanderthal and
Homo Sapien I know it's really unclear
how much inner breeding took place in
the early days of humanity but whether
but now you have my respect that's the
thing do it doesn't go like that just
stop and if it does I don't want you
saying it I think that pretty much is
how it goes I just not not like this
like this you've had my interest now you
have my attention
what's the phrase take wait a minute I
stopped it go away
wait Oh Archie had a chance Mannlicher
been friends Oh wild not gonna be artsy
get a marketing arrow baby oh oh wait no
hang on
you absolute feline wait I'm going to
ask you something in art are you in a
relationship with that cat mark you know
that it's not real right you wait online
relationships are will relationship so
will you
people look at that that teamwork what
is this this conspiracy something going
on here this okay maybe not a conspiracy
no they're throwing up off their scent
we know what's up hey stop look you
throw me a bone just to make me feel
better what are you gonna do if I skip
art you gonna retaliate you gonna get me
give you another turn oh well if I do
this to Archie huh what do you think
that I'm gonna get a turn why don't you
challenge me you dumb cat man I feel bad
now up on us I forget your previous
betrayal of me Bob to me against the
world that we are both being unfairly
treated and I play look at that
Archie made it red Red's the color Wade
wanted last round can i play
Clark you keep gaining cards I think
you're doing it wrong you want less
cards have a turn thank you thank you
thank you I'll take two please do I
won't because we're a team
[Music]
never happened team winners two born
again
Marcus curb my flier my applier mom our
names do not mixed yeah that's not good
yeah my plier Marcus curb yes my marks
complier yeah I feel like I get kind of
shorted on that actually I don't like
that one yeah that's not a lot of you
but I mean you get the most important
part the skirm bob is that one I thought
for a second Wade's brain was too
dedicated to coming up with names that
he couldn't be bother to play completely
gone
combine this how does it fit mask
betrayal he fives me okay okay maybe
you're right maybe you're right maybe
you're on our feet it ended up hurting
me too so I really don't know well even
better
well don't take your rage out on me do
you want m8 doesn't matter
oh wait blue it is I could have screwed
Wade over if it was a different color
well here what if I'm just one of these
good gentlemen's right here Oh double
scoop go again man
no after you sir oh now I can screw Wade
[Laughter]
no challenge of job 30 Artie jumped in
to save you back on we knew it all along
way the view in this cat are boning and
probably other stuff yeah online cash so
you admit it
I basically pleaded guilty in court oh
my god how could he play this we've got
them we've got them mark what color do
you need technically orange teammate I
can't do that one but I've drawn these
cards for you
[Laughter]
the teamwork really does Hajis listen I
you've got some winners on the other
side work is unreal this teamwork is
something else oh goodness me we don't
want that we don't want that here Bob
you don't have to be your usernames out
what Bork
Tippie Bork I guess if I have to choose
listen we're just gonna leave it blue I
can do anything I could have done stuff
to you I want you to know what's gonna
happen to wane old buddy thanks buddy
Thanks yeah you draw before
[Music]